hi my name is abu bakker salim i play
bike
in assassin's creed origins i auditioned
for it um
through my acting agent thinking that it
was a animated tv series it was
advertised as an
animated tv series and um
with motion capture and yeah so i went
to it was like a standard audition
um got into the room had sides
did my lines and then got to the second
round
and then at the second round they told
me it was for a video game for
assassin's creed
to which i lost my mind and um and where
we they ended up saying that okay
so because it's for because it's for
motion captions because it's for the
video game the way that they did the
audition and the way that
they filmed the audition was that they
used a bigger space so there wasn't any
tight shots so there wasn't any sitting
down or standing it was
they wanted to see me move and i
remember that process being really
different to
to other to other auditions because
normally you're just sitting down and
it's still and it's all within the face
whereas in this one specifically they
wanted your body
and yes that was that was how i got into
it really yeah
there is this huge like you know realm
of possibilities of
because you got to think of the player i
think there's a lot of you know you've
got to really think of
you know the player choices and you've
got to be able to
perform you know with the same intensity
depending on what the player chooses
and so you know there's a lot more kind
of there's a lot more stories you know
there's a lot more branching off
whereas you know where's tit film and tv
is quite linear you know video game
it's very much like a tree it could
branch down this way or it could branch
the other way or
you know so you've got all these other
choices that you've got to play with
and um and it's a challenge it is a
challenge and um
but at the same time it's so much fun
you know it's so it is so liberating
because it is
like it is that it goes back to that
feeling of
okay let's imagine that we are over here
or let's imagine we made this choice
so you've got all these different things
to play with welcome breakthrough rich
so uh how did the the whole breakthrough
think uh thing come about
for you individually each hey i was
i got contacted my agent to to apply so
you apply and you submit like
your body of work and why you think you
should be breakthrough bit
i feel like you must be like can you not
do that for me you know you'd be like
okay and then you but i don't know it's
easy when you put it down into words and
then you realize what bafta kind of
means to you and
um which is what for you
i suppose it is i don't know test it i
think it is just
it's just a wealth of talent that you
get to celebrate
with and also the the way in which they
support
their talent as well like after
breakthrough
you know you get mentorships and they
kind of like
you know support you throughout the year
yeah yeah or you get to go to amazing
events like this
where you're given an order am i right i
am how you feeling about that it's fine
we just checked
yeah it's great good well done yeah yeah
i think uh if i just like
because normally many people have been
in the industry for years and they're
absolutely
in it yeah i think i'll just find
someone in the crowd like de niro
just eyeball him with the whole thing
yeah i was like why is she eyeballing me
what have i done
looking at me i think if you went in and
looked at the whole room you might pass
yeah yes yes you do what about you how
did it come about for you sir um
i produced a film called animal i know
it yeah well done thank you thank you
emma jane underwear yes and so uh and
that was considered um you know my
breakthrough
project uh and therefore yeah i get to
be part of this amazing
group of people and to have the
incredible support of bafta so yeah it
feels like a real privilege
how was that for you to make by the way
oh it was incredible so proud that's a
book i think that really it's
interesting it's got such a cult
following that book
it does it does indeed yeah it was a
real labor of love um it took us many
years to get the
the finance together and we had an
amazing team of people and we had an
absolute blast making it so
it was really important to us to tell a
great story about female friendship
about women who are flawed and messy and
behave
as women do um and we're really proud of
the results so
well done and also just getting i mean
you know my wife works in filming
actually just to get
a film to option a book so then get it
made
that's i mean that's a victory in itself
thank you it feels it feels that way
five years in the making
so my name's abubakar salim i'm an actor
and i'm a breakthrough brit okay
i started with theater i did my first tv
job at i think 16.
went to drama school did some more
theater then i did the video game
it was a pivotal moment for me anyway it
shifted a lot
of how i would then approach characters
for tv
and film you're putting in at least you
know 100 hours worth of
voice work and acting into a character
and you're having to get the audience to
kind of do
enjoy listening to you for that long
that really informed
the way in which i approached work
afterwards
best piece of advice that i was given
was brush your teeth daily
genuinely but if we're talking you know
in the art sense
uh just be honest
ultimately you're more interesting as
you as an individual
rather than like let's say the character
you're playing or whatever you know i
mean like
for me it's it's it's all about honesty
it's all about connecting with someone
on an honest level
raise bubbles is definitely my
breakthrough role
simply because it's the biggest project
i've worked on i'm working with ridley
scott
and her also put me in a position where
i've had to take the lead yeah
definitely a breakthrough role yeah i
have no idea what could
what what the future now holds it's
exciting but it's also terrifying
because you don't know what's gonna
what's gonna happen right it's it's
brilliant
real cool what about you mr assassin's
creed mate
literally i was just walking to the cop
and found out i got it so i was just you
know
kind of like one of those winnings so
yeah no no again it was one of those uh
things that again my agent called up and
said i think you should do this and i
was like okay
sure go for it and uh yeah and then here
i am thinking that oh wow
i want like a lottery ticket yeah yeah
but it's just been it's just been
wonderful i mean i've done a lot with
bafta anyway especially with like the
game awards
and um uh being nominated like two years
ago with assassin's creed
so it's just been wonderful to be also
recognized within this sort of film and
tv area as well because
you know again that's that's what i'm
when you go to act as a character in
in a game yeah i'm a big gamer when you
go to academy so what do you
how does that physically manifest itself
when you go into a studio
and with all the movements and the voice
booth or how does it how does it work
exactly
it's the same thing as it's like a mix
of tv and film it's like you're in a
massive volume like a warehouse with
250 cameras on you you're wearing a
beautiful tight like pursuit which i
think you look beautiful
and uh yeah no worries and then
literally yeah it's just you're doing
scene after scene off the scene
it's it's like a mix a hybrid of theater
and and and
uh film and tv sounds like long days
yeah it's it's long i mean i was on
assassin's creed i did that for a year
and a half
i was just in and out of the studio in
montreal just doing it and it was
it was but it was exhilarating it's so
liberating as well like it was
it was beautiful yeah congratulations to
all of you well and having good agents
too
[Laughter]
i'm lee valger i'm an actor and i'm a
breakthrough brit
my introduction to acting was probably
making little short sketches and movies
when i was a kid
and i'm like the youngest of five so i
took it upon myself
to entertain and make my my siblings and
my family laugh
i suppose i'm drawn to filmmakers who
don't shy away from
portraying the truth in a in the most
kind of honest
and gritty way where it's not airbrushed
it felt and not in an arrogant way but
it felt really right
when i was involved in the virtues
because
i think it's because when i was growing
up and when i was really focusing and
studying acting i just
watched all his movies all the time i
played the character
called dina she's a bit of a troubled
character with like a checkered past
the first day on set where you know dean
is introduced into the story
i remember like read the read the script
and i was like that is the coolest way
for a character to be introduced into a
television series where you know
you know literally comes in with a bang
the lovely thing about breakthrough is
it
it doesn't just celebrate actors you got
producers writers directors
what is so interesting about this
industry is that people come into it
with
a such a diverse background
you know no one has gotten where they
are there's no two people that would
kind of got got into acting and got
direct in the same same way and i think
that's what it is it's just like
a collaboration of creative misfits who
have all just decided to
tell stories i think there is so much to
mine from that way of storytelling i
think video games
is i mean it was my way in i mean i
remember as a kid i
you know i i was dyslexic i couldn't
read books
uh you know tvs shows and films i didn't
really connect to because there wasn't
any
person i could really connect to but
video games because it is so interactive
and and it involves
you you know in the story and going on
this journey
with this character you know it was
it was it was just so it was it was so
cool to you know to kind of get involved
in so i
i love the idea of being able to tell a
story
that way through a video game through
someone you know going on this journey
with me
interactively spending eight you know
hundreds of hours with me
you know seeing this world that has been
created by you know
these people who really love what
they're doing and yeah i think
i definitely want to want to venture
more into that and
see more into that and play more into
that absolutely
the one thing that's kind of that i've
tried to really do
is just focus on my own journey
not compare myself to other you know my
peers
and just try and just do what i love
and kind of keep that love going and
keep fighting and keep going because it
is tough
it's it's you know there's i could be
working now i could be doing these great
interviews now and then i could you know
in a month's time i'd be at home
twittering my thumbs probably playing my
game
but like it's like it's a you know it
can shift and change so quickly
but i think it there is that if you
really want to do it and you know you
and you really feel like this is this is
this is for me just keep going
it'll happen it will happen because you
know the more you kind of give off to
the universe it will give back in some
way shape and form
[Music]
you